Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Vous connaissez certainement
ce schéma que je vous présente
actuellement derrière moi.
Ce schéma représente nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre à tous.
Nous émettons,
collectivement sur la planète Terre,
50 milliards de tonnes
d’équivalent de CO2.
Ce CO2 que nous émettons
est réparti en cinq grandes catégories.
D’abord l’industrie –
ce que nous produisons ;
l’énergie –
la manière dont nous la distribuons,
dont nous la produisons
représente également 30% ;
puis vient ce que nous cultivons –
l’agriculture avec 20% ;
ensuite le transport –
comment nous nous déplaçons,
ces marchandises que nous déplaçons,
avec 15% également ;
puis enfin,
la manière dont nous nous chauffons
ou nous nous refroidissons, avec 5%.
En France, cela représente,
0,5 milliard de tonnes
d’équivalent de CO2.
Pour un Français, vous, moi,
c’est environ 11 tonnes.
Si nous voulons respecter
l’Accord de Paris,
il va falloir passer de 11 tonnes
à 2 tonnes.
Alors, bien sûr,
vous avez entendu parler des écogestes…
dans le domaine de la consommation :
consommer responsable,
éviter de gâcher,
mieux trier ses déchets,
acheter seconde main ;
dans le domaine de l’énergie
avec l’efficacité énergétique,
souscrire à des fournisseurs
verts d’électricité ;
ou bien dans le domaine du transport,
évidemment,
où on nous dit :
« il faut éviter de prendre l’avion,
prenons le train, le vélo », évidemment.
Mais tous ces écogestes, finalement,
ne représenteront que 20%
de l’effort à faire.
Les 60 autres pourcents, seront un effort
que devront faire
nos collectivités territoriales,
nos entreprises,
ces organisations collectives.
Examinons maintenant,
le rôle de la technologie.
Souvent, on entend parler
de la technologie comme étant
le troisième plus gros consommateur
d’électricité au monde,
si c’était un pays.
L’intelligence artificielle,
dans ce contexte-là,
évidemment,
consomme beaucoup de ressources.
Elle consomme des cartes graphiques,
elle consomme des serveurs,
elle consomme
des ordinateurs qu’il va falloir produire,
toutes ces puces…
Elle va nécessairement polluer
avec des process de traitement
de récupération de ces terres rares.
Dernièrement,
on a même entendu
que la plus grosse
des intelligences artificielles
consommait l’équivalent
de 300 équivalents-tonnes de CO2
juste pour sa phase
d’apprentissage et d’entrainement !
L’intelligence artificielle pollue.
Mais ce que j’aimerais
voir avec vous aujourd’hui,
c’est plutôt de voir
l’intelligence artificielle
comme une opportunité,
comme, finalement, une technologie
qui pourrait nous aider
à répondre à ce défi collectif
que nous avons.
Et si l’IA, finalement,
pouvait sauver la planète ?
J’aimerais vous proposer trois exemples :
l’industrie, vous vous rappelez,
c’est l’équivalent de 30%
des gaz à effet de serre.
Si on prend l’exemple du ciment.
Le ciment, aujourd’hui,
la manière de calculer
le coût carbone
d’une tonne de ciment produite,
c’est un calcul théorique où on va
regarder comment on a extrait
les différentes matières premières,
comment on a injecté
les différents combustibles
dans le four
qu’il faut chauffer à 1 400°C,
les différents adjuvants…
pour faire
un calcul théorique et dire:
« le ciment qu’on produit aujourd’hui,
il émet tant de CO2. »
Mais qu’est-ce qu’il se passe si –
une usine de ciment utilise
des tracteurs électrifiés
plutôt que de l’énergie fossile,
ce qui se passera si plutôt que
de mettre en combustibles fossiles,
plutôt que de mettre que
du pétrole et des déchets de pneus,
on met d’autres types de combustibles ?
En fait, on n’en sait rien aujourd’hui.
Donc qu’est-ce qu’il faudrait faire ?
On va pouvoir mettre,
par exemple, des capteurs
de gaz en haut de ces cheminées,
qui vont nous permettre vraiment
de savoir en temps réel,
combien nous émettons
de gaz à effet de serre,
de CO2, de méthane, ou autres,
sur ce ciment qui sort de cette usine.
Et là, ça change tout.
Parce que, l’IA, qu’est-ce qu’elle va
pouvoir faire avec cette nouvelle donnée ?
Elle va pouvoir optimiser
les process,
les paramètres des différentes machines,
pour pouvoir produire ce ciment
avec un carbone le plus faible possible.
Autre exemple - l’énergie.
L’énergie est également responsable
de 30%,
on disait tout à l’heure,
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Aujourd’hui, il y a encore 80%
de l’énergie qui est produite
dans le monde
qui vient de la source du pétrole,
des énergies fossiles.
C’est l’Agence Internationale de l’Énergie
qui a sorti son plan pour atteindre
la neutralité carbone en 2050.
Qu’est-ce qu’ils disent ?
Ils disent : « il faut arrêter
tout projet d’exploration
de nouveaux champs de pétrole,
de nouveaux champs de charbon,
de nouveaux champs de gaz, et il faut
déployer massivement
les technologies propres.
L’eau, le vent,
les marées, la chaleur du sol,
toutes ces technologies propres ;
et en particulier deux,
l’éolien et le solaire :
à équivalent de 600 gigawatts par an pour
le solaire et environ 400 pour l’éolien.
Soit environ quatre fois les piques
qu’on a connus en 2020. »
Ça va être un déploiement massif
qu’il va falloir réaliser.
Et ces énergies, alternatives,
ont donc une particularité…
parce qu’elles sont aussi décentralisées
sur des réseaux bien locaux.
Que se passe-t-il pour savoir comment
la consommation qu’il va falloir produire,
va être accepté par le réseau ?
Quelle inclinaison
de mes panneaux photovoltaïques ?
Est-ce qu’il faut mieux
stocker l’énergie que je vais produire
ou au contraire,
la diffuser dans mon réseau ?
Est-ce qu’il faut mieux que
je la vende sur mon réseau ?
Tous ces paramètres, sont également
aujourd’hui, traités
par une intelligence artificielle –
qui est un orchestrateur
de finalement tous ces paramètres
pour pouvoir diffuser
une énergie verte à moindre cout
et l’IA ici, va aider
à accélérer la transition énergétique.
J’aimerais vous parler
maintenant de notre environnement
et du CO2 en particulier.
Le CO2, il est absorbé
par une technique naturelle.
C’est la forêt, c’est nos océans,
c’est la culture végétale.
Ce phénomène naturel
que vous connaissez tous
s’appelle la photosynthèse.
Chaque année, c’est 20%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui sont absorbés
par ce phénomène naturel.
Et la forêt en particulier,
environ 10 milliards
de tonnes équivalent de C02.
On comprend pourquoi c’est important
de préserver nos forêts.
Je vais justement vous raconter
l’histoire d’une forêt.
C’est une forêt en Suède qui va mal.
Elle est attaquée non pas par l’homme
cette fois-ci, mais par un insecte.
Un petit coléoptère de 4 millimètres.
Il est dévastateur.
Il tue et ravage toutes les forêts.
Il fallait donc trouver une solution.
Aujourd’hui, les gardes forestiers
qui vont sur place
pour identifier si oui ou non
cet insecte est présent,
s’ils devaient courir toute la surface
des forêts de Suède,
ils mettraient des dizaines d’années.
Là, l’intelligence artificielle
a été utilisée pour observer
les images satellites
et identifier dans quel cas
il y a un risque d’infection.
L’algorithme a appris pour pouvoir aider
à reconnaitre en anticipation,
l’arrivée de cet insecte !
Et aujourd’hui, en temps réel,
elle communique les coordonnées
de ces forêts, les points GPS
aux gardes pour qu’ils aillent sur site
et éviter que cet insecte se répande.
Cette fois-ci, l’IA a aidé à
préserver nos ressources naturelles.
Voilà, bien sûr,
l’IA consomme beaucoup de ressources,
elle peut faire peur de temps en temps.
L’IA peut aussi
nous aider en fonction
des secteurs industriels à réduire
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
à hauteur de 45%.
Mais aujourd’hui, c’est seulement 3%
des entreprises qui se saisissent
de l’intelligence artificielle
comme solution possible
à la réduction du CO2.
Alors, je vous ai présente trois exemples.
J’aurais pu vous parler de l’IA qui sert
à écoconcevoir des nouveaux produits.
J’aurais pu vous parler d’une IA
qui sert à reconnaitre
les déchets plastiques dans nos océans,
pour guider les bateaux
et récupérer ces déchets de ces océans.
J’aurais pu vous parler d’une IA
qui va optimiser les flux logistiques
ou bien prédire
la fin de vie des équipements.
Il existe des centaines
et des centaines
de cas d’usages référencés
dans la littérature scientifique.
Alors la question qu’on se pose tous,
quand on produit, qu’on crée
ces nouvelles IA, c’est finalement
ces consommations énergétiques,
ces équipements, ces matières premières
qui nécessitent à faire cette IA –
est-ce qu’elles valent le coup
par rapport aux bénéfices
qu’on peut en tirer ?
C’est sûr, seule,
l’IA et la technologie ne sauveront pas
l’homme et la femme le pourront.
Mais pour autant, l’IA
est belle et bien une solution
qui pourra nous aider à sauver la planète.
Merci à tous.